dining room absolutely crucial we can't
do without you and you can't do without
us and we got to establish that teamwork
and we've got to come together as a team
and think together as a team and then
never forget the most important person
is the customer so it's a very
straightforward exercise Nick and I are
gonna arrive in the dyeing room for the
first time we've got a table booked for
1:30 for lunch today
ready sit me down present the menu and
sell me this restaurant here you Peter's
been here for 15 years so you should
know what he's doing good afternoon mr.
Whitehurst nice to see you mr. Ramsey
time to see you I got a nice table for
you yeah well you can't fault his
enthusiasm still or sparkling phase of
his bottom my sparkling I love a bearish
Kim's been a waitress for five years
she's charming but has no real training
a bit bitter bitter okay the lamb
perhaps yeah sex only been here a week
he knows nothing really nothing where's
it from the loop I'm not too sure thank
you um Oh super the day six today not to
show you them so amazing water pee still
spoken yes sir we're still fresh whole
fresh or new God fresher from the pond
on the ninth green I would like you all
to have less than 48 hours to master the
new menu and be able to sell it to the
customers got bits of mussels in it it's
not actual fish is it I'm not sure right
it's safer yeah it's it's in me a
seafood soup is guys got some whitefish
there Coco's Coco's goggles this is
gonna be harder than the kitchens I used
to work as a waiter but I'm sure I can
show them how it's done
it's no cutter chatter peaceful creamy
so damaged the flakes of oat smoke how
to finish with a wonderful poached quail
so there must be chowder be chowder
definitely not we
have a special on today clam chowder the
chowder the Charlie's a very nice
platter
it's very nice please platter that's it
man nice short descriptive idea with a
special clam chowder very strong tasty
I'm telling [ __ ] great there have to
be the menu for the menu what I'll give
I'll give the menu to you there you go
okay Hanneman am you see we got nothing
sharp tasting but a special twist to it
as we put quail's egg in it what quails
they did it much better
quail said in it really did eat my pubes
are going great garnished with a oaks of
haddock flake and so garnish any cook
know this whole thing is theater and
this freshman has to become a showcase
and each and every customers gonna eat
in here on Sunday gearing up for a
bloody busy day has to remember you yes
I remember you and we serve good food
boy are they gonna come back depend on
one last chance for Zach here we go
nobody this one I can feel in my bones I
can see how relaxed you are you're
looking good you're cool you do the bow
give it to me the smoked haddock jellies
a very nice dish
it has a nice creamy fishy garnished
with flakes and a nice smoked haddock in
the middle he's been selling like
hotcakes it would be funny it wasn't for
Mother's Day see Oh buddy man left to
nice to prepare those those right oh
look you know you got two days preparing
one [ __ ] speech I've got 24 hours
again [ __ ] mission ready Zach Zach